I'm ashamed that it took me 18 years to
spend today with my daughter
I'm ashamed of being sort of friends
with a bull he's mean to me as well well
I don't really hang out with him but he
like came out with me and I hang out
with his friends that are not police but
they say he's mean to
but we're afraid to not play with them
because then he might really as more
than
don't be friends
[Music]
no matter what they tell you they'll
give to you or anything
is our first date in 18 years so why did
it take her mother and I were young and
we were in different relationships and
[Music]
some secrets are left secrets for a
while and then they can't be secrets
anymore so it was the first time you
guys in that yeah
[Music]
so how does it feel hanging out with
your dad for the first time definitely
not shameful it feels like long overdue
[Music]
I'm ashamed of one whenever people leave
me out
and
there was this kid his name is he's in
my class and whenever whenever I'm
playing soccer with him he he just
leaves me out so so I just walk away and
and he's just laughing another real
night how did that make you feel
[Music]
okay do you make sure that you don't do
that to other people yes that's good
that's really good buddy you're still
great you know that I waited a long time
to go back to school and I guess I'm
ashamed and I'm not in a place in my
life where I could help my family more
calling my mother I hypocrite when I was
a teenager for wanting to live with my
boyfriend at the time why is that the
first thing that came to mind because it
was I a machine
he's got your mom right there she's
great he never apologized
I'm ashamed of making it up a lot of my
never realizing how happy I am
I pretended to be
and
schizophrenic and everything because I
thought that's what I was that
how were you able to like get past that
a lot of it was because of my
girlfriend's a lot of ass-kicking from
her and really it was it was an
awakening
I am ashamed of my depression and
anxiety and
what it makes me do to myself physically
and mentally
[Music]
I'm ashamed of my scars and I actually
pull out my hair due to the anxiety and
I have to constantly cover up and buy
makeup to cover it up because it's very
noticeable if I don't stop my hair a
certain way
yeah I just really wish I had never
started doing that because it would have
saved me a lot of time and money if I
hadn't started doing that do you have
any advice for like other people who are
maybe going to seek help it's really
hard for me and myself to seek help but
it doesn't have to necessarily be like
going to a therapist it can just be like
going out to like the park with a friend
or a co-worker and just like letting
them know like just being honest about
how you're feeling is the best thing you
can do to people because it gives them
like an idea of what you're going
through and you don't have to suffer in
silence in high school I wasn't a very
nice person and I think it had to do
with a lot of myself being very insecure
so I was mean to a lot of people and if
I can go back I would like apologize to
a lot of people I'm sorry guys I've
changed
I grew up I'm mature and I'm a lot more
secure about myself and I'm sorry I
brought a lot of people down just to
make myself feel better I think I'm
ashamed probably of how long it took for
me to like be myself
like I'm
[Music]
and that was like it's a really long
process for me I think it took a year I
was even dating somebody and like to
tell anybody and like it was hard and I
was really ashamed at the time and now I
think I'm ashamed that I was ashamed I
know I guess like my body sometimes I
feel like I've done a lot to get over a
lot of things that I used to be ashamed
of that I'm not ashamed of anymore it's
good so
[Music]
the list is shorter these days I am
definitely ashamed of feeling like and
never accomplished what it should be
accomplishing on the day-to-day basis
feeling stuck and just makes me feel
very unfulfilled and feeling like I'm
not putting it as much effort as it
should be into what needs to be done I'm
not brave enough to talk about my
decision I'm kind of like so a lot of
people are very anti-catholic so I guess
I'm very shy about standing up for what
I believe it so I'm not very good at
talking to people I'm pretty shame with
that
kind of weird so I'm not really good at
interacting with people
not being good enough what do you mean
by that you know you have like does just
feel like you're not just good enough
for anything
oh god I have no shame
okay why do you say that well I don't
think I should have any shame for being
Who I am worth doing what I do I'm proud
of Who I am I like myself
I'm ashamed of how often my fake
meditate you know with my girlfriend's I
tell them that I you know I've dated and
everything I know all about dating and
the truth is I've never dated I am
single
I'm ashamed of letting my son know how
his father and I met I'm so ashamed of
my skinny legs but they don't bother me
that much
cuz I got some amazing fragrance you
know when I am you see I'm a fairy now
no so my my hair is like it's no growing
too much so when he's like he said a lot
of people and it's windy especially when
it's alone another is that with my hair
is like Shh
and I see that my you know it's not a
lot of her like I'm getting all you know
that's why I put the hats when either
win now I can tell you it's like
yourself like self-conscious you know
problem but it's not a problem you know
about this is now there are surgeries
and stuff and money when he's winning I
guess I wish I did like that's a shame
I'm ashamed of
[Music]
not opening up to a bomb will I lost my
virginity trust in your parents or
anyone near you that's willing to be
open about it and to accept you for it I
knew I had my mom but I think that I was
ashamed of doing it at such a young age
and I knew she would probably be
disappointed so I kept it in for a very
long time when I cuz I can say hey no me
siento it goes up at the moon eco camera
piant oh it was a super honest Africa we
know a two-hour water table when I was
in media es una didn't eat it yo
Pensacola is young correcta pero con los
años no safe way or no fuera easy on
correcta entonces es la única cosa creo
superfood super defense hora de ella
Berto pero ya ahora
despues it como un tiempo los or aplenty
and momenta las casas e que lo que noise
noise until Sara Gonzales in Oh como que
cuando se esta committees to Nairobi em
where tenesmus Michalek Agosta tienes
que reflection are sobre o acetate oma
tiempo Tito Munoz udderly
otro significant a Christmas a is not
calling my dad dad he is my stepdad but
he's raised me and so he's my father
figure but I don't even though he like
he is my father and I talked to him as a
tease my dad I don't say in business I'm
ashamed I have to be afraid of who I
love
yeah
what do you mean by the
[Music]
Oh No
I have a lot of pain in my life and I
feel like I'm undeserving of love
[Music]
so I have a lot of fear behind them I
don't know how to explain it when I was
very young I let a family member
pressure me into trying drugs and
[Music]
I should have never done it but it's
just hard when somebody is like in your
face and go with your days and then many
years later it comes back to bite you in
the butt because you're trying to tell
somebody don't do drugs and then those
same people that were pressuring you
into trying it or telling you that you
have no business telling somebody else
not to try drugs because you've tried it
so don't do drugs you know watch for the
first time in my life I actually have no
shame I had carried shame for the better
part of my life and then I worked on
myself I mean and my issues and my
secrets and all that and now I'm
actually at a point in my life where I
don't feel a lot of shame
so I'm actually happy about that I went
into therapy I went into sexual abuse
therapy to actually be specific and I'm
not ashamed of that anymore I used to be
very ashamed of that so that's I went in
for sit for a few years probably two and
a half and I feel like like a weight has
been lifted off my shoulders and you
would not believe my name is Mariah and
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask the new year's to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
don't need a lot thank you